apple just released a second developer
beta of ipad a wes and with that comes a
new SMB server connection feature with
iPad OS we're already able to connect
everything from hard drives to flash
drives to easily access files and copy
them to the local storage we have a full
guide on how to do that which you can
check out by clicking the card above but
for this video we're gonna show you how
to wirelessly connect to a hard drive
nass or server over an SMB connection
the beauty of this is that if you love
using your iPad for editing photos or
videos or doing production work you'll
be able to access all the files on your
hard drive or server as long as you're
connected to the same Wi-Fi connection
that your router outputs modern Wi-Fi
routers allow you to connect storage to
them either by a regular USB connection
or with an Ethernet port the more
advanced server storage systems include
Ethernet ports for simple connections
straight into a router and they also
have applications and instructions on
how to connect using SMB the common
person won't have one of these they'll
have a regular hard drive SSD or maybe
even a flash drive they want to connect
to so let's go through the steps on how
to do this first off you'll need to
access your router settings through our
web browser that's connected to your
routers Wi-Fi network if you're not sure
how to do this
refer to your routers user manual our
router tells us to go to this website we
already set it all up and created a
password so we'll just log in now here
in our dashboard we see a section for
external storage which is empty so let's
go ahead and plug in a simple flash
drive into the USB port on the back of
the router back at the router settings
page our drive now shows up so let's
click manage storage and right here you
can see a MAC access address with SMB
right in the beginning of it now let's
go back to our iPad go to the files app
and tap this little edit icon within the
Browse tab then tap connect a server and
type in that SMB address and hit connect
now you can simply connect as a guest
but if that doesn't work you can
register as a user most user accounts
will be named admin by default and the
password should be the same password you
use to log into router settings if not
you can read through your routers manual
to set up your external storage in
account name and password we already
have a large a hundreds harab is Mb
service setup and we've logged into it
on our iPad so here it is within the
files app and as you
see we now have access to up to a
hundred terabytes of files we use every
day for editing videos and everything
else we do browsing through all the
files is super quick no lag or low times
at all and here's a video playing it
opens up just fine and plays back fairly
smooth but not perfect since it's over
the Internet and not straight off a
physically connected drive we can easily
tap and hold a file to drag it and tap
on even more files then open the on my
iPad location and drop them right in
surprisingly the transfer speed is very
quick considering its downloading the
files using Wi-Fi and there you have it
those files are now on local storage
even better let's use split view to open
up the loom of huge in video editor now
we can drag and drop files straight from
the SMB server into luma fusion and
start editing this is great because if
you make any changes to files on your
server on your Mac or computer it'll
instantly be updated on the iPad and if
we didn't have SMB server support we'd
have to transfer files from the server
to a flash drive and then from the flash
drive to the iPad if you haven't watched
your iPad a West multi tasking guide you
can check it out by clicking over there
and if you enjoyed this video tap like
and hit that circle above to subscribe
so you don't miss out on more videos
like this one thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]